you constructed this golden rectangle
right
but i want you to do a few more see this
rectangle in here
because it's similar to the big one you
should be able to do to this
what we did to the original shape you
should be able to divide this up into
a square and another golden rectangle
and a square and another golden
rectangle
and a square and another golden
rectangle you should be able to go in
reasonably far
okay now when you do this
i'm going to ask you to create another
shape we did the golden rectangle gold
ratio
look for the great pyramid which is a
golden pyramid i suppose
you're going to make the golden spiral
here's the way you
build it see this square actually look
at all the squares okay
i'm going to draw a quadrant in each one
a quadrant
it's going to look like this is one
quadrant
okay it's an arc there the next one is
going to bend around like this okay
the next one's gonna come around like
this
okay and then in and then
don't pack up yet okay now you're like
look
i told you the golden ratio is all over
the place remember that quote ubiquity
right just have a look at these pictures
for me
what is that
that's a that's the shell that's the
shell of um
a nautilus right someone lives in the
sea do you recognize anything about that
yeah well how about this
do you recognize anything about them